so I can put on these these funny little
shoes and actually walk around the
chairs maybe we want to do that with the
camera afterwards you can walk around
the chair you can look underneath and if
you and you you don't need to teach
anyone how to use the system in that way
because you they put these glasses on
and they walk around there's no
knowledge needed about how do i navigate
in the model how do i interact with the
model you just do it naturally cave I
think it's actually an abbreviation
computer automated virtual environment
that's it you have an environment if you
wish made out of projection screens
where you can immerse yourself into a
virtual world you can do the same thing
with HMDs with head mounted displays we
have the screens directly in front of
your eyes but that has some
disadvantages you don't see yourself you
don't see your environment you stumble
over things if you walk so we're doing
this right now you're not seeing much of
it you have the screen of a 3d cinema in
this case fourfold so you have a room
that's made up of projection screens and
you have 3d stereo projection and what
these glasses do is they're basically
the glasses themselves are basically the
same as you would have them in in 3d
cinema but they're tracked that's why
they have these little funny balls on
them and the cameras that you have on
the top of the screen and also two at
the bottom they tell the computer where
the tracking target is and that way in
real time the perspective from what you
see the environment is perfectly adapted
to these classes so if I walk through
here I always have the perfect
perspective and it feels like reality
that's why it's called virtual reality
that might actually be a cool effect if
you walk around like that one thing
you're walking on a projection screen
that's fine if your shoes are halfway
clean we're fine with that but we have
people scratch the floor
exactly
I'll turn the 3d off now you have a
single picture and if I turn it through
yon again you'll see that the further
away the object is the further apart are
two pictures and obviously that's the 3d
stereo effect that you have a picture
for the left eye and a picture for the
right eye which gives you the depth cue
yeah it's a building we're in I'll give
you these again so so the views perfect
for the camera so I can not only move in
front of the building here obviously I
can fly through through the whole model
and I use this funny little fly stick
for it it works the same way as the
glasses - we have a tracking target on
them and so I'm doing kind of a Superman
move I'm just pointing where I want to
fly and that way I can fly through the
model sure I'll give you something to
look at here so I'll fly into the
building so now we're inside the
building and this model of this building
has existed when here in reality there
was still green field so we could be
walking through a labs we were able to
look at our offices to look at all the
facilities but long before they were
even built so we could tell the
architects okay this is fine but we want
this to be different so we had a virtual
prototype of this building long before
the building existed and with this
prototype we can make corrections that
at a later point in time would have been
very expensive to correct the virtual
model was easy and cheap to correct the
actual construction would have been a
lot harder and a lot more expensive and
also during the building process there
were some some difficulties that we
could cure with the help of virtual
reality if you look for example at this
staircase we're looking at your
staircase from the bottom and it has
kind of a fun
weird geometry - it has this twisted
geometry and the people who were
supposed to make the concrete for this
they had to deep aper plans so we took
them to our old virtual reality lab and
they looked at it in 3d in virtual
reality walked through the building
looked at that at the staircase like
we're doing right now and within ten
minutes they they knew what to do and
they understood that principle is what
we are promoting here we look at virtual
models virtual prototypes first see
whether we can see any mistakes get new
ideas corrected virtually first look at
it again and when we feel confident to
build the actual real prototype then we
do it I can actually show you again what
the what the tracking does so we'll fly
into this room over here you can walk
around the chair you can look underneath
and you don't need to teach anyone how
to use the system in that way because
you they put these glasses on and they
walk around there's no knowledge needed
about how do i navigate in the model how
do i interact with the model you just do
it naturally
if you imagine to have not a chair here
but maybe a prototype of the latest
machine of some company then you can
imagine engineers walking around the
machine like that and discussing about
the machine I was telling you earlier
about the six-sided cave we had if you
imagine a full cube of projection walls
that's quite a cool experience to be in
there because you're fully surrounded by
virtual reality you're moving through
virtual - through a virtual world you
don't even see the real world anymore
you're fully immersed and it's actually
so so real that you move within the
six-sided cave for about two minutes you
will forget this the projection wall
that you can actually open you won't
know where to go anymore we actually
needed a system to make sure that people
find their way out you could push every
wall and the right wall would beep and
then would open because people would get
lost the disadvantage of that is that
first of all the light
is only you only have light from the
projectors in a 6-sided cave so if
you're in there with two people people
look kind of weird they have like this
funny dark there they're kind of a dark
shade of the of themselves so if you
have engineers who actually want to work
in that system it's quite a weird
experience and also they're completely
in virtual reality if they want to have
a table to take notes if they want to
you know go back to a meeting situation
they can't and this is why we designed
this cave the way we did by first of all
having a large power wall where you can
have large models but also having kind
of an open layout with a meeting meeting
room right there go back and forth
actually from virtual to normal reality
do you want to see the the back of
things like the technical stuff this is
only the projectors that are computers
there's 13 of them are downstairs
they're not actually not very special
computers they're normal consumer
computers that you can buy they just
have really really good graphic cards
and two of them each and yeah very good
gaming cards that's that's basically
what it is and as you can tell these are
not your normal office projectors either
they're quite big quite expensive they
actually use a lot of electricity the
only reason we have the mirrors is so we
don't need neat as much room if you
point the projectors normally at the
projection wall you'd have to turn them
the right way just by turning them 90
degrees and have these mirrors you just
save some room because we want
resolution we have four projectors on
this wall you could nowadays also use
one 4k projector if you wanted but that
again would use up a lot more room
because that would have to be further
back again the floor is done from above
you could also do the floor from below
we've done that before that again uses a
lot more room you need another story
actually down
yeah downstairs so overall we have 11
projectors here for for this big wall
and if you come around here yeah sorry
there's a two more over here and then
two more again on the on the short side
there it actually uses the heat to feed
the heating system that way we don't
have to feel that bad for using up all
this energy a couple of years ago you
would do everything to get as much light
onto the projection wall as possible and
what we're doing here is actually a lot
of things that use up light the first
thing after the lens is this filter over
here and you can see that the dark
border and you have that dark border to
stitch together the pictures of the four
different projectors in a way that they
fade in into each other nicely and but
that uses light that makes everything a
little darker and then we have a
projection wall that's also almost black
which uses up light again and like I
said a couple of years ago people would
have said this is crazy you can you can
just take away light we need as much
light as we can get nowadays the
projectors are so strong that we can
afford to have black projection walls
because these again make your contrasts
a lot better you have sharper contrast
and better individual pixels this is a
normal a full HD solution so so 1920 by
1080 so the whole wall is almost a 4k
resolution I can tell you that the whole
system the way it's built here was about
1.2 million euros sometimes it does go
wrong but compared to systems we had
earlier this is really nice and stable
what we're using right now here mainly
is our own software so if you have a
computer game they're usually not
capable in a real time system with more
than one visual channel and these this
is 11 visual channels so that's quite a
step actually but like I said we're
working on making unity work
for that unity3d is a game engine within
a couple of months I think we'll be
there so there could be computer games
developed for for the system which would
be great fun
everything about that to the power has
led me to be the scientist laughs I have
things my brain hunter another thing
here so that's going to be zero and if
we run those values through again zero
minutes one to work